perché amiamo le regole le regole
rappresentano il controllo in qualche
modo il sapere cosa ci aspettiamo cosa
ci può arrivare dalla realtà è la forma
più sofisticata di di controllo è in
qualche modo la predizione la predizione
a scrutare il futuro anticiparlo in
qualche modo esorcizzare le nostre paure
su quello che deve succedere e la
scienza ha fatto della predizione uno
dei suoi concetti centrali in qualche
modo ci ha avvisato
noi possiamo andare su internet e
trovare tutte l'eclissi di luna per le
prossime centinaia di anni con
precisioni infinitesimali
abbiamo anche imparato a rilassare in
qualche modo il concetto deterministico
di predizione siamo tutti abituati ad
andare a guardare le previsioni
metereologiche a capire che c'è il caso
e c'è quindi una probabilità associata
alle previsioni e quando parliamo di
previsioni metereologiche cerchiamo di
pensare a quelle previsioni che ogni
anno salvano migliaia di vite per le
tempeste tropicali per i cicloni per
tutti quegli eventi in cui possono
essere usate queste queste idee per per
evacuazioni per per prepararsi e in
qualche modo la predizione diventa anche
costruzione con le regole con le
predizioni scientifica possiamo
immaginare nuovi materiali pensarli in
un computer studiarne le proprietà
possiamo immaginare le proprietà e
aereodinamiche di un aereo
prima di averne mai assemblato un pezzo
in qualche modo sono dei successi
straordinari a cui però non corrisponde
invece un aumento della nostra capacità
di controllo su tutta una serie di venti
che forse sono quelli che più ci
preoccupa in questo momento non
controlliamo i conflitti sappiamo
predire le epidemie sappiamo predire la
gestione delle emergenze
sono tutti i punti interrogativi in
realtà per lunghissimo tempo
e ancora adesso abbiamo problema a
immaginare anche la predizione di un
ingorgo in qualche modo in un mondo che
è sempre più interconnesso in un mondo
che ha sempre più come dire esposto a
quelle che sono delle piccole
perturbazioni che possono poi
riverberare attraverso tutto il sistema
in maniera anche anche catastrofica e
perché non riusciamo a fare predizione
perché non riusciamo a controllare
questi sistemi
fondamentalmente perché al centro di
ci siamo noi c'è l'atomo sociale e per
l'atomo sociale c'è una regola
purtroppo che per lungo tempo ci ha
detto che in qualche modo siamo
imprevedibili impredicibile tutti noi
abbiamo una complessità cognitiva
psicologico che ci rende diversi
dall'atomo fisico tuttavia consideriamo
che c'erano delle eccezioni ci sono
state per lungo tempo degli altri modi
di pensare anche nella sociologia in cui
in qualche modo si immaginava la
costruzione di una fisica dei sistemi
sociali partendo dall atomo sociale
dall'individuo per costruire le molecole
la famiglia il posto di lavoro poi
assemblare queste molecole per infine
arrivare all'aggregato sociale capire
l'aggregato sociale come il fenomeno
come il fenomeno emergente in qualche
modo poi non siamo così impedibili per
il 90 per cento delle cose che facciamo
non lo siamo
questo ovviamente ha una visione
ambiziosa che si scontrava con vari
problemi e negli ultimi anni negli
ultimi e nelle ultime decine di anni ci
sono stati due grandi rivoluzioni che
hanno permesso a questa rivoluzione di
finalmente cominciare ad incarnarsi e
sono fondamentalmente due la prima è la
rivoluzione della scienza della
complessità la scienza della complessità
si occupa di tutti quei sistemi fatti da
molti individui interazioni molte parti
e le interazioni possono essere sistemi
fisici ma essere sistemi biologici
e ce l'ha insegnato che il mito della
beresina non esiste non c'è lab e
reggina che comanda i soldati lavoratori
e così via ma in realtà c'è una società
che attraverso poche interazioni può
costruire fenomeni magnifici senza il
leader senza un progetto in qualche modo
ma attraverso fenomeni emergenti e
questo ovviamente possiamo considerarlo
anche anche per la società
poi c'è un'altra grande rivoluzione
della rivoluzione dei dati perché se
vogliamo studiare l'atomo sociale
vogliamo fare una fisica sistemi sociali
dobbiamo riuscire a prendere dei dati e
il problema è come fare degli
esperimenti non siamo certo un sistema
fisico non ci possiamo mettere in un
laboratorio bene in questi ultimi anni
c'è stata una rivoluzione dei dati che
ci permette finalmente di guardare alla
società in una maniera completamente
diversa pensate che ogni anno vengono
accumulati più dati socio economici che
in tutto il periodo precedente della
nostra umanità e questi sono dati che
arrivano in varie forme non sono solo la
digitalizzazione degli archivi sono per
esempio le tecnologie pervasive sono il
fatto che tutti noi possiamo avere dei
piccoli sensori e possiamo misurare le
interazioni tra tra persone con
precisione infinitesima anche in questo
caso come in una scuola e guardare come
i bambini in una scuola possano possono
interagire quando sono in classe quando
sono ricreazione e possono possiamo
pensare a questo in un ospedale in una
conferenza nella società in qualche modo
vedere come noi parliamo interagiamo
fisicamente possiamo spostarci a un
livello più alto guardare la società
ancora più da lontano e guardare i dati
che produciamo che ognuno di noi con i
nostri telefoni con i nostri device
mobili produce questa e parigi la notte
della festa della musica e queste sono
persone che si spostano da una parte
all'altra della città e che possono
essere inseguite digitalmente guardando
guardando le tracce dei dei telefoni
cellulari
e poi possiamo guardare ancora più da
lontano il globo in qualche modo
possiamo vedere come ognuno di noi ogni
tanto sale su un aereo e in poche ore si
trova in un altro continente e quindi
per esempio monitorare tutto quello che
è il traffico aereo al di sopra degli
stati uniti o in tutto il globo
ognuna di queste tracce un aereo delle
persone che sono dentro che
rappresentano degli spostamenti
ora immaginate di mettere tutti questi
strati uno sopra l'altro e di guardare a
questo mondo in una maniera
completamente diversa è un mondo che di
cui noi possiamo finalmente avere i dati
di cui abbiamo bisogno
il problema è che i dati non sono la
predizione non sono il controllo per
avere la predizione dobbiamo avere dei
modelli i modelli sono una comprensione
del dato che ci permettono di proiettare
la realtà nel futuro sono la nostra la
nostra sfera di cristallo e questi
sistemi sono dei sistemi appunto
complessi sono dei sistemi e
fondamentalmente eterogenei fatti da
tante parti e in questi sistemi noi
dobbiamo abbandonare una delle cose a
cui siamo più familiari in qualche modo
che è il pensiero lineare cos'è il
pensiero lineare ma innanzitutto che non
se noi prendiamo due molecole di acqua
non riusciremo mai a capire quando
l'acqua diventa ghiaccio quando è un
liquido quando è un vapore dobbiamo
guardare a miliardi e miliardi di queste
molecole insieme e poi dobbiamo
immaginare lasciare un altro dei
concetti a cui noi siamo familiari che
impariamo quando abbiamo quasi tre anni
che ha una grande perturbazione del
sistema corrisponde normalmente una
grande risposta del sistema ea una
piccola perturbazione normalmente una
risposta infinitesima del sistema bene
nei sistemi complessi non è così ogni
tanto piccolo perturbazioni possono
avere effetti catastrofici in alcuni
casi grandi perturbazioni vengono
riassorbite dal sistema che si adatta in
qualche modo dobbiamo acquisire una
prospettiva completamente diversa che si
concentra sulle interdipendenze del
sistema e come facciamo a lasciare il
nostro pensiero lineare in qualche modo
usando un nuovo pensiero che è quello il
pensiero computazionale perché appunto
essendo senza senza bussola quello che
noi possiamo fare invece usare il
computer dove il computer diventa non
più quello strumento che serve a
trattare dei numeri a fare delle
operazioni numeriche ma diventa un
laboratorio diventa il posto dove noi
analizziamo i dati estraiamo regolarità
statistiche creiamo dei modelli e
riusciamo a capire il sistema ad
esplorarlo diventano il microscopio che
al contrario del micro scopo del
microscopio che ci permette di guardare
l'infinitamente pili infinitesimamente
piccolo ci permette di guardare in
qualche modo il collettivo
l'infinitamente grande ma ha fatto
dall'aggregazione di tanti e di tanti
elementi bene questa è una visione
ambiziosa e si può partire si può
partire e cominciare a costruire per
esempio qual è il profumo dei problemi
che abbiamo e predire la diffusione
delle epidemie
beh cosa dobbiamo fare partiamo di nuovo
dall'atomo sociale partiamo dagli
individui dove siamo dove viviamo come
siamo distribuiti sul sul pianeta mappe
di grandissima accuratezza e poi siamo
noi che trasportiamo le epidemie
i virus hanno bisogno di noi hanno
bisogno di trasferirsi attraverso i
nostri contatti e quindi in qualche modo
dobbiamo mappare in questo universo i
nostri spostamenti dobbiamo vedere come
viaggiamo come interagiamo come ci
muoviamo da un posto all'altro bene in
questo mondo sintetico che noi andiamo a
creare possiamo introdurre degli
individui infetti e cercare di fare
predizioni sulle epidemie bene non c'è
un modello che soddisfa qualunque
infezione dobbiamo considerare se
parliamo di una influenza se parliamo di
ebola se parliamo della salsa ci sarà un
modello per ognuna di queste infezioni
ma se abbiamo abbastanza dati possiamo
cominciare a scrutare nel futuro a fare
cosa a guardare il sistema per creare
queste micro simulazioni che ci
permettono di seguire gli individui uno
per uno come salgono su un aereo
come portano l'infezione attraverso il
pianeta
seguendo realmente il cammino
dell'epidemia nelle sue come le
definiamo autostrade in questi alberi di
invasione del mondo per cercare di
capire come dove e quando l'epidemia
colpirà ovviamente questa è una
simulazione in un computer che va
ripetuto tantissime volte per cercare di
estrarre quelle regolarità statistiche
che ci servono poi per cercare di
anticipare di nuovo in maniera
probabilistica cosa possiamo aspettarci
dall'epidemia le cose ci possiamo
aspettare nel 2014 dalla grande e
purtroppo preoccupante epidemia di ebola
nell'africa occidentale un'epidemia che
purtroppo vede all'opera un'infezione
che ha una mortalità che si aggira tra
il 50 e il 70 per cento e che ha un
potenziale pandemico
beh è quello di usare questi strumenti
per cercare di capire di anticipare per
avere un intelligenza di quello che
succederanno il futuro ad esempio
immaginando quale sarà il cono di
proiezione del numero di casi di
fatalità che possiamo aspettarci dalla
dall'infezione quanti persone si
ammaleranno come queste viaggeranno nel
sistema di trasporto globale e potranno
arrivare in ogni paese possiamo
proiettare le statistiche di quanti casi
possiamo aspettarci in ogni paese
123 che possano arrivare in un posto e
iniziare nuove nuove epidemie nuovi
focolai in qualche modo informazioni che
possiamo sfruttare per fare politiche di
contenimento di mitigazione per cercare
di ottimizzare la distribuzione delle
risorse cercare di nuovo di confrontare
e combattere un futuro che in questo
caso diventa diventa preoccupante però
le epidemie in qualche modo sono il
grande esempio del contagio e il
contagio è qualcosa di molto più ampio
il contagio non è solamente il contagio
biologico il contagio è anche quello
delle idee
è il contagio del consenso politico è il
contagio della conoscenza tutti i
fenomeni sociali di contagio in cui noi
ci contagiamo uno con l'altro è una
maniera che è molto simile a quella
biologica
la differenza è che il contagio sociale
avviene in uno spazio diverso non è più
lo spazio fisico dell'interazione non è
la geografia ma avviene in quello che è
uno spazio sociale uno spazio sociale
che è diverso che è un lo spazio delle
nostre amicizie delle reti sociali dei
nostri contatti che possono essere per
telefono attraverso lo scrivere in forme
infinitamente diverse che per tantissimi
e tantissimi anni non abbiamo neanche
immaginato di poter mappare di avere una
reale geografia di questo spazio sociale
e invece lo possiamo fare adesso per
esempio con i dati con la rivoluzione
dei dati possiamo guardare a twitter e
possiamo guardare ascoltare le nostre
conversazioni
questa per esempio a una rete dove i
nodi sono degli individui le connessioni
luciano il fatto che ci si ripete dei
messaggi e le connessioni arancioni e
che si menziona qualche altro individuo
all'interno dell'ecosistema twitter
vedete che ci sono due grandi comunità
queste conversazioni sono le
conversazioni che si concentrano sugli
aspetti della politica degli stati uniti
e potete bene immaginare di cosa stanno
parlando queste due comunità sono due
comunità 1 e la parte repubblicana e
l'altra da parte democratica due
comunità che sono coesi tra di loro e
che hanno pochi scambi in qualche modo
tra i tre i due opposti campi e vedete
che in qualche modo questa è una mappa
di quello spazio sociale precisa che ci
parla di quali sono le relazioni degli
individui beh possiamo fare di più di
questo possiamo addirittura aggiungere
la dinamica di questi fenomeni
possiamo immaginare per esempio sempre
di ascoltare di ascoltare twitter o
altri segnali di visualizzarli nel tempo
di contestualizzarli di nuovo nella
geografia di vedere ad esempio come si
propaga si propagano le idee delle
proteste del 15 maggio in spagna come in
qualche modo nascono dei focolari di
discussione che porteranno il
15 maggio delle grandi proteste di
strada cominciamo ad accedere a questi
dati per poter creare dei modelli di
contagio che finalmente ci dischiudono
il futuro anche dei sistemi sociali dei
fenomeni collettivi sociale e questa è
una grande rivoluzione una rivoluzione
dove in qualche modo abbiamo un passato
un passato che è quello del dato come
fotografia statica del presente e quindi
già che già si riferisce al passato
invece abbiamo un dato che è quello del
dato moderno come trattiamo i dati
moderni che è un flusso un flusso
continuo che entra dentro i nostri
modelli e che in qualche modo ci dà un
aspetto dinamico che ci permette di
sfruttare all'interno del futuro e di
dare quella capacità predittiva che ci è
sempre mancata quando parliamo del
sociale
questo è è un enorme cambio di paradigma
è un mondo in cui passiamo da delle
eccezioni ha delle regole queste regole
che diventeranno sempre più comuni la
nostra capacità di poter scrutare il
futuro in aree situazioni che noi non
abbiamo mai potuto neanche immaginare
diventerà sempre più comune ovviamente
diventa anche in qualche modo
inquietante il pensare di poter guardare
al futuro dei sistemi sociali come
regola come come visione che possiamo
acquisire è qualcosa che ci disturba è
sempre qualcosa che ci ha resi non a
nostro agio però dovete immaginare una
cosa quello di cui sto parlando non sono
regole che definiscono il futuro
questi metodi questo tipo di approccio
ci dà delle cartine geografiche per dei
viaggi per cercare di capire dove stiamo
andando
ma la scelta finale di quale strada e di
che cosa noi faremo per andare nel
futuro dipende da noi in qualche modo è
una scienza che ci dà una carta
geografica ma non ci dà la soluzione
finale grazie